joining us now from pittsburgh to
discuss this is dr amos shedalgel he is
senior scholar or a senior scholar at
the johns hopkins center for health
security at the bloomberg school of
public health good morning doctor
just have to say now the ball is in the
court of the cdc that now that the fda
has
authorized the children's vaccine from
pfizer for kids 5 to 11.
the cdc is likely to give it a thumbs up
what's your reaction
this is going to be something that will
be a relief to many parents of five to
11 year olds whose children's lives have
been on hold whose children's lives have
been held hostage by covet 19 not
necessarily seriously sickening them but
disrupting their lives in terms of
virtual schooling and isolation and
quarantine and there are high-risk
children that are going to benefit
greatly from this vaccine and i think
we'll all benefit from having children
vaccinated because the more shots that
are in arms the harder the job of the
virus is to spread
doctor that's uh kids now as for adults
millions now qualify for the booster as
you know but it can get confusing
between mixing and matching and
everything else what what's the urgency
level for people right now who were
fully vaccinated earlier this year
boosters aren't going to change the
trajectory of the pandemic it's first
and second shots to do that but there
are high risk groups that would really
benefit from a booster particularly
those above the age of 65 those with
high risk conditions and anyone who got
the j j vaccine those should be the
people that are trying to schedule their
boosters now and if you got the j j
vaccine it might be beneficial to get
the modern or pfizer vaccines because
they have a different type of technology
in them and that mixing and matching
boosts different parts of your immune
system and you might get a bigger boost
than normal so those are the people i
think really need to get a booster today
you mentioned the path of the virus you
said recently that we are now in the
endemic
phase of covid what exactly does that
mean
what it means is that covet 19 is not a
disease that can be eliminated it can't
be eradicated it's something that's
going to become one of our seasonal
coronaviruses we have four other
coronaviruses that cause 25 percent of
our common colds this is on its way to
that and that means that we're going to
have a baseline number of cases
hospitalizations and deaths but the goal
is really to tame it to remove its
ability to crush hospitals and that's
what vaccines do that's what some level
of natural immunity will do that's what
monoclonal antibodies do and upcoming
antivirals all of that is going to make
this a much more manageable disease so
we've got to teach people how to risk
calculate and make good choices because
covet 19 is going to be with us in all
of our activities there's never going to
be a covet zero time along those lines
and referencing back to the term fully
vaccinated which we've used a couple
times now with boosters does what fully
vaccinated means change
right now the public health agencies
like the cdc are not changing what it
means to be fully vaccinated so that's
two weeks after your second dose of
modern physio or two weeks after your
single j j dose and i think that makes
sense from an operational standpoint but
obviously
from an individual health benefit there
are people who would need to get
boosters like the immunosuppressed like
those who are elderly those with high
high-risk conditions because that's
where we've seen some erosion and
protection against serious disease but i
don't think that makes sense to change
what the definition of fully vaccinated
is because it's going to be very hard to
actually implement that or to actually
use that for people for example trying
to partake in an activity but people
should stay up to date on what they
require for their conditions even if it
doesn't if the definition doesn't change
okay dr emma shadalja as always thank
you very much